the economy of course back open after
the covid crisis but not everything will
come back including three local casinos
thanks for joining us at six i'm brian
loftis i'm kirsten joyce the casinos
that will remain closed and set for
demolition fiesta rancho texas station
and fiesta henderson 8 news now reporter
sasha loftis joins us with more details
we've done several stories on these
properties over the years speaking to
neighbors who say they hope one day they
would reopen now they'll have to wait
and see what happens the announcement
came just after noon today these three
have been closed since the pandemic back
in 2020 the facilities at the properties
other than the ice rink at fiesta rancho
will remain open but everything else
will be demolished according to a
statement from red rock resorts the
properties have been an important part
of their business for many years and
they're sad to announce these permanent
closures they added that approximately
one-third of the team members from each
of these three locations have been
working at other station casinos
properties i spoke with two people who
used to work at two of the properties
here and they shared their memories with
us working over there my co-workers were
like a family you know
and since that time i was
i was so this was fun with me working
with them a lot a lot of memories over
there all three of these properties were
built in the 1990s no word on when any
demolition will start we put a poll out
on twitter asking which of these three
locations were your favorite so far
viewers say texas station followed by
fiesta henderson reporting in north las
vegas tonight sasha loftis live local
now
thank you sasha henderson mayor deborah
march releasing a statement saying in
part quote while we are sad to bid
farewell to fiesta henderson we are
excited to welcome new development to
henderson that will bring economic
benefits to the community